بحسب نتائج دراسه عالميه جاءت دوله
الامارات على راس قائمه 12 دوله ارتفع
فيها نشاط رياده الاعمال بنسبه بلغت 12%
ثم تليها كولومبيا السعوديه وقطر وتايوان
والهند وهولندا وسويسرا وكوريا الجنوبيه
ضمن الاعلى تسجيلا للانشطه التجاريه
وشركات الشخص الواحد الخدمات الاستهلاكيه
هي الاكثر شيوعا عند اطلاق مشروع جديد
وتمثل ثلثي الشركات الناشئه الجديده في
اربعين من اصل 49 دوله في الخليج وامريكا
اللاتينيه يتبنى رواد الاعمال التقنيات
الرقميه الحديثه في اداره اعمالهم الصغيره
بمعدلات اعلى من المناطق الاخرى حول
العالم في السعوديه يؤمن 90% من المواطنين
بانفسهم وقدراتهم لتاسيس عمل تجاري اما
اليابان فتحتل المرتبه الادنى في هذا
السياق بين الدول المشاركه يميل الرجال
لتاسيس الاعمال التجاريه اكثر من النساء
باستثناء اربع دول وهي اندونيسيا بولندا
قطر وتوجو
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]